we're joined now by craig mccart he is
the deputy chief of criminal
investigations for the indianapolis
police
have all the victims been identified
have the families been notified
so now unfortunately we are still
processing the crime scene
yeah and and part of that processing
obviously is
is also identifying all of the victims
and so we have not done that yet
we're working with families we have a
reunification center right now that's up
and running at a nearby hotel
we have our victim assistance units
there to assist in that process
but the crime scene processing is
it takes time it's lengthy and certainly
as part of that we're going to get the
victims identified as quickly as we can
so that we can get those families
notified
they've certainly had some uncertain
hours so we're working to do that as
quickly as we can
yeah i understand do you know how many
people were injured
and and what condition they're in at
this moment
so the last thing i knew we had we had
four
people who were taken from the scene
with gunshot wounds
um another person who was transported
from the sea
with some other sort of
wound possibly from shrapnel and i
believe
at this time all of those victims are
stable
the the shooter reportedly died by
suicide
do we know anything about the shooter at
this point do anything
do we know anything about a possible
motive for this
no again we're in the same boat kind of
with him as we are with the victims
because we have not
finished processing the scene we have
not identified him
and obviously until we identify him we
can't really start digging into a motive
or any anything like that too much do we
know what type of weapon he used
we believe that he had some sort of a
rifle was the shooter already deceased
when you when you arrived
my understanding is we're still trying
to confirm this my understanding was
that he
had already taken his own life when
officers entered the facility
[Music]
what do you see happening now deputy
chief how long do you think before we'll
have our our next update on this and
and how much longer do you think you
need to be processing this scene well
again
um with with multiple victims like this
and a crime scene that part of the crime
scene was
outdoors part of it was indoors so
there's there's a lot of processing that
needs to take place
um that needs to be completed before we
can really jump into the other part of
the investigation which is looking into
the suspect
and and looking into those possible
motives that we spoke about earlier that
we just we just don't have an idea right
now so
um it's it's certainly going to take
some more hours to complete that
and i i don't expect to really have any
more significant information until
probably later this afternoon at the
earliest all right
deputy chief craig mccart with the
indianapolis police department thank you
so much for your time
thank you